la fidélité il risque une réussite dans
la réussite d'un coupon avec nous ce
soir
lina b quiche vous êtes avez vous êtes
une femme qu'ils avaient été trompés
vous avez fait le buzz en dénonçant l'
infidélité de votre mari dans une vidéo
sylvie vous votre mari avait une double
vie après 29 ans de vie commune
m q n'y est avec nous merci m e claire
beitia lisez vous êtes là vous êtes
avocat spécialiste en droit de la
famille et merci d'être là excusez des
voix là franchement excusé on a
également avec solène panier vous êtes
directrice de la communication du site
de rencontres extraconjugales gleeden
voilà donc c'est un nouveau site en fait
voilà où il ya eu des vraies pannes ont
en fait me disant à cette année
calmez-vous commun et alexandra
choukroun psychologue clinicienne ou le
fait d'être infidèle peut parfois
permettre de tenir le coup donc vous
êtes pour certains cas et ianao me know
me dit ça vous ne pouvez pas vous
empêcher de tromper vos partenaires oui
mais moi l'infidélité
ça a toujours été comme ça depuis que
j'ai mes premières relations voulais
témoigner directement fait envie mais
maintenant j'assume à moi je suis mes
femmes non j'ai assumé tout le monde
l'est c'est donc à vous allez nous en
parler dans un instant alors
l'infidélité une réussite pour un couple
oui ou non ici au tour de table n'a pas
de oui franc on voit voilà que vous êtes
tous des menteurs
non mais c'est vrai parce qu'il n'ya pas
de wii front il ya des oui un petit peu
mitigé karim zéribi battu que j'attaque
avec ça c'était on est mitigé parce que
je pense que il n'ya pas une clé pour la
réussite d'un couple et ce serait
prétentieux d'imaginer que de la main de
l'endroit où je parle je suis pas
psychologue jeu super g page est pas là
ni la compétence ni la capacité d'avoir
analysé des couples infidèles ou pas
pour savoir si c'est la clé de leur
réussite il y en a certains certainement
qu'ils vont chercher une forme de piment
une forme de l'exaltation de
l'infidélité puis en a certains qui le
vivre est certainement très mal et qui
ont besoin au contraire de vivre à
travers un contrat de confiance absolue
et je veux dire chaque couple a ses
particularités
c'est ce qu'il faut à mon année avoir
une approche
néral l'infidélité oui si la clé je sais
pas moi dire ça veut dire et le cubisme
en fait c'est pas la réussite mais c'est
l'épanouissement mon avis si on t'a
tromper c'est bien ce que tu faisais pas
bien l'amour
sexton c'est tout tu seras non on va
vous parler dans un instant on
s'engueulait où on va on va d'abord en
parler et vous vous engueuler répression
loin que ses rimes
il n'y a rien de plus mystérieux qu'un
couple et je parle pas seulement du coup
que je forme avec les bruits de seconde
arrêtez la clim l'on n'en peut plus en
plus la dame est très peu habillée voilà
oui c'est vrai arrêtez là que je disais
rien de plus mystérieux qu'un coupé je
parle pas seulement de celui que je
forme avec eric zemmour qui est très
mystérieux en effet mais il n'y a pas de
règle
hélas ce que j'entends dans la sphère du
single mais ça veut dire on va voir
ailleurs une fois par mois
c'est une volonté de normaliser des
choses d'instituer un contrôle social et
même un contrôle économique parce qu'on
sait bien que des tas de gens vont
s'engouffrer dans la brèche pour essayer
de fournir des partenaires une fois par
mois
moi ça me choque qu'on ne laisse pas les
gens vivre leur vie mais que ça passe
toujours par des démarches commerciales
des démarches normalisée vraiment je
trouve que c'est contraire à la vie
alors voilà 55,05 thuel si oui mais son
état ne pas laisser les gens vivent
devenir un peu naturel spontané sauvage
leur quoi pourquoi on jouait pas disent
oui c'est ça pas une fois par semaine
personnel c'est plus d'informations
demain dans ce cas deux botteurs poser
comme question à mademoiselle deux pieds
second est ce que vous êtes mariés voilà
alors c'est à mon avis un cas un petit
peu à part pardonnez moi n'est pas
dépourvu voilà il n'y a pas d'incident
sont mariés sont mariés et là ils ont
décidé des libertins au bout de au bout
de cette ambition donner
est-ce que vous avez envie de construire
un moment donné un coup puisque vous
aurez envie alors moi déjà je suis
bisexuelle donc actuellement si je
préfère les femmes ou les hommes et moi
je suis aussi pour la relation polyamour
sauf que moi le problème c'est que je
trouve personne qui accusait pékin
moi je trouve aucune personne qui
accepte ma façon d'être
ouais j'aimerais trouver à une relation
polyamour bon ça va s'arranger après
cette soirée
attendez attendez vous à quelques
filtres à vous donner
l'infidélité en suivant bien aux 55 %
des hommes ont déjà été infidèles
alors d'après la police nationale c'est
ce qu'il avoue exactement ce qu'ils
versent et plus d'un même sur deux s'il
avoue dans une enquête
donc là si on prend à peu près tout le
monde dans cette salle vous en serez pas
bien sûr mais je pense que à visage
découvert tout très peu de gens vont
témoigner ou dans le public
voilà alors pourquoi les français
sont-ils infidèle il yal'envie de
changement le besoin de savoir si on
plaît encore besoin de séduire le sexe
et les disputes conjugales
alors vous vous lire agir vous pensé et
je suis très étonné que l'infidélité
n'est pas un gage de réussite pour le
couple ou es ce que vous avez déjà est
infidèle non plus depuis longtemps fait
vous êtes seul non je suis accompagnée
mais l'amour l'amour et ses dix est
opposée c'est pas différent ni autre
chose s'est opposé à l'infidélité
l'infidélité c'est pour s'éclater
bon c'est autre chose quand vous dites à
votre femme chérie je reviens je
m'éclate et à nous c'est bon ça passe
très bien pour la fille des noms manque
de confiance en soi et qu'on a besoin
d'aller se prouver quelque chose
ailleurs
alors bon
lina wina vous êtes une femme vous avez
été trompés vous avez fait le buzz en
dénonçant l' infidélité dans une vidéo
va voir cette vidéo et vous à nous
raconter votre histoire
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
aux copains
voilà donc vous avez cassé
donc c'est dans l'appartement de votre
ex voilà pour l'ameublement
l'électroménager boum boum
[Rires]
alors c'est incroyable parce que quand
on quand on voit ça alors
li na racontez-nous ce qui s'est passé
mais m'a brisé le coeur je vais te
briser dans l'appart
alors qu'est ce qui en fait ni comment
ça s'est passé vous avez découvert si
vous aviez vous étiez en même temps
comment vous étiez avec lui depuis
combien de temps
trois en trois ans donc et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé mais il m'a trompé on vous
l'avez appris il s'est affiché avec des
photos que j'ai découvert à travers des
amis oui et on a du coup fait une petite
technique pour le faire sortir et
rentrer tout déglingué à l'intérieur
d'accord ou simplement vous avez été
blessé
oui beaucoup énormément mais j'ai très
vite compris que coller la faute ne
venait pas demain en fait justement
c'est pas moi qui n'ai pas combler un de
ses besoins
c'est lui qui manque de confiance en lui
c'est lui qui a besoin de d'aller voir
ailleurs pour se prouver quelque chose
c'est d'un staff personnel j'ai l'âge et
excuse pas tu me coupe pas dans ce cas
faut pas son âge je veux rester
célibataire qui vous attrape avec elle
la demi-heure vous quand même j'adore
les bébés avaient mis % avec quel type
de temps dans ma foi pas encore été
arrêtée on va pas rentrer là c'est très
joli tout ça me plaît
j'aime bien le cac lâché sur le look du
manque de confiance entre mieux mais
voilà si je vais donner d'éléments façon
maintenant je veux deviendra très fidèle
mois n'aura des valeurs très jolie pas
deux mais bien sur place et une femme
belle des coupes en rien ce que vous
dites là donc ça sert à rien berisha
pour l'homme mais n'est pas le sien pas
fait pareil
est ce que je voulais dire c'était pas
méchant ce que je voulais dire mais dans
le jeu en fait c'est assez curieux film
tu avais chine que deviner la tomette
l'état les voir ailleurs parce que tout
y est les croyais jamais que c'est pas
ça l'amour c'est pas la classe
de l'autre ça j'ai l'amour c'est à
accepter que l'autre puisse s'amuser
c'est ça l'amour mais vous ne parlez pas
ne saurais pas vous sortir de mes parts
joli ça va disparaître ces deux sujets
c'est un sujet délicat
oui c'est vrai non mais pardon mais
l'amour c'est pas ça du tout mais non
l'amour c'est un sentiment sonné le au
canal est l'amour c'est un sentiment si
l'infime unités contre les abattages est
temps d'être ici parce qu'on attendait
si l'infidélité construisait un couple
ça se saurait l'infidélité ça détruit un
couple parce que l'infidélité à mon avis
pas dans l'est je donne mon avis après
ou dans l autre
la finalité construit de l'infidélité en
moins à mon sens un vous êtes de plus en
plus infidèles et vous vous êtes
l'exemple même de ça parce que vous
n'êtes pas mariée vous n'avez rien
construit un couple ça se construit dans
la durée avec des eaux avec débat avec
des difficultés mais si on cède à la
facilité comme toi tu es si on cède à la
facilité de faire je vais mettre entre
guillemets pour pas trop vous choquer
tout et n'importe quoi
eh bien on construit rien et on est en
couple si ce qui vous arrive alors on va
on va écouter suivi pour vous bien sûr
la vie déliter n'est pas une réussite
dans le couple vous vous avez vous étiez
dès que votre mari depuis 29 ans oui et
vous êtes rendu compte qu'il avait une
double vie non je m'en suis pas rendu
compte c'est lui qui me l'a avoué elle
vous l'avouer fabriqué moi comment ça
s'est passé alors donc bah il m'a dit
qu'il avait plus de sentiment que
je pense que ça c'est connu tout jeune
en fin de compte à l'adolescence ouais
et donc et vivent une double vie depuis
combien de temps depuis deux ans depuis
deux ans il était avec quelqu'un mais
c'est à dire qu'on vous dit la double
vie avec une collègue de travail donc
c'est elle qui est venue me la prendre
c'est lui qui m'a dit qu'il avait plus
de sentiments pour moi mais je ne savais
pas qu'il avait quelqu'un en train je me
suis douté mais quand elle est venue à
la maison et elle est venue chez moi à
la sonees genre salle des scellés qui
s'est passé sur wii bhl oui qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en fait elle a sonné
chez vous oui et puis elle s'est
présentée et là elle m'a dit ça fait
deux ans que je suis à votre mari un oui
d'accord vous l'avez dit quoi bien faire
prendre un verre non mais je suis resté
très calme
oui parce que j'ai des enfants quand
même donc j'avais pas envie de leur
montrer une agressivité quoi sas pour
moi ça servait à rien donc je suis resté
très calme et puis après j'en ai discuté
avec mon ex mari quand il est rentré du
scandale alors vous avez dit que vous
l'avez dit de la personne et de la wii
je lui dis bah la maîtresse est venu à
la maison
ah oui et lui le dieu alors sympa et
vous a dit quoi ah bah non pas français
expliquer tout ça donc après je vais dit
qu'il fallait qui parfois et l'épargné
tout de suite bah oui le oui de ce soir
mais les adeptes avec sa maîtresse où il
est né en un an il est parti chez sa
maman s'est passé je devais fidélité
certes mais c'est la fin d'une histoire
oui s'il l'a fait c'est que il l'a dit
il l'a reconnu à chaque humain c'était
la fin de l'histoire
donc pour pas faire mal il a commencé
effectivement avoir d'autres sentiments
pour notre femme voilà tout moment où
c'était ma mais c'est à dire éviter pour
faire mal c'est terminé voilà j'ai des
relations pour une autre fois il faut
quitter la personne un vent de la
tromper sur le court alors d'accord il
attire le courage et ça c'est facile de
dire ouf et dieu je vais quitter la
personne etc
mais c'est pas toujours s'est pas fait
jouer comme ça ma question de force
s'est pas cassé de fourrage
ces questions de vis est question de
contexte c'est chaque jour pendant
compte que cinq éditions beaux tissus
que la demoiselle qui a tout cassé tout
à l'heure et pour moi l'infidélité
et à la fois une grande partie de manque
de confiance en soi d'être infidèle
lorsqu'on est un fidèle
une grande part pas tous les couples pas
tous les infidèles il ya beaucoup de
manque de confiance en soi mais aussi la
façon dont réagit à une infidélité
il ya aussi un manque de confiance en
soi oui la façon dont réagissent vue
d'éditer je pense qu'il faut savoir
doser savoir faire face aussi à une
infinité parce que ça renvoie à certains
à la peur d'être quittée des réactions
un peu d'enfants quoi car il veut mais
moi ce que je crois c'est qu'on voit
bien les positions des uns des autres
n'y a pas de science exacte dans la
réussite d'un couple il n'y a pas de
recette magique je veux dire et
l'importance mais non madame excusez moi
je pense au temps autant les êtres sont
différents ce qui fait la richesse d'un
couple si on peut s'exprimer vous
exprimer après les séries c'est bien le
dialogue c'est quand même qu'on puisse
se partager les amis différents et pour
moi la réussite d'un couple c'est que
quand deux personnes se rencontrent et
partagent la même conception du couple
c'est ça le soit un final au final à la
conception jusqu'à réalité c'est que
l'infidélité
quand elle n'est pas partagée elle fait
du mal même quand elle est partagée le
fumeur mais je peux vous justement karim
wade alex là que moi et vous vous dites
que le fait d'être infidèle peut parfois
permettre de tenir le coup et on ne doit
pas avouer une infidélité
pascal auriat dont il ya deux cas ou
l'infidélité effectivement peut
permettre entre guillemets de maintenir
un couple c'est lorsque par exemple
lorsqu'on a construit une famille des
enfants et qu'il n'y a plus d'intimité
dans le couple il peut arriver que
certains trouvent ce compromis
donc ça peut maintenir ce qu'ils ont
construit voilà alors que ce soit 10 ou
non dit mais comment sait on peut dire
alors dans le deuxième cas si vous
voulez c'est lorsque effectivement il y
à des personnes qui ont continué d'avoir
des sentiments où ils ont traversé une
grande crise et au delà de cette crise
ils ont réussi à traverser à dépasser à
communiquer et ils en sortent grandis
mais après ils ne sont plus infidèles
donc
il y à vraiment deux cas de figure en
généralement comme ça ce qu'il faut le
dire on peut le dire ce que je sais
alors si c'est pour si c'est une
démarche parce que le l'infidélité ou
l'adultère il faut le prendre comme un
symptôme d'une problématique non résolus
dans le coup notamment quand il ya une
chronicité dans le temps et dans les
sentiments et à ce moment là si c'est
pour quitter la personne et que la
personne enfin la personne n'arrive pas
à quitter
peut-être qu'il faut parler de la vraie
problématique c'est à dire de passer le
pas à rompre mais si c'est un écart tad
et caetera et qu'on n'a pas envie de
quitter la personne
je ne vois pas pourquoi ça sert pas le
dire faire du mal d'avantagés d'essayer
de sortir de cela et d'aller au fond du
vrai problème
eric naulleau mais on l'entend de choses
gérant chez chez vous mesdames est dans
ce qu'on vient d'entendre
il ya des leçons tirées de la vie de
l'expérience de la vie chez vous
mademoiselle je regrette mais comme vous
n'êtes pas en couple comme vous avez
jamais qu'un faux nom mais jamais contre
un couple dans la durée donc vous savez
j'ai fait trois ans de relation
non mais vous êtes pour un principe
d'irresponsabilité trois ans ce n'est
pas beaucoup je veux dire que voilà moi
j'entends des gens qui tirent des leçons
d'une expérience longue de coupe ou
d'une expérience théorique ou d'une
expérience pratique et vous vous arriver
en disant moi j'ai la recette pour tous
âges et j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de rien
c'est l'irresponsabilité
ça n'a aucune valeur s'est jamais dit ça
nous dit l'amour c la liberté alger
suite à l'essai modèle naomi elles se
protègent davantage parce que elle sent
que peut-être les regards vont la juger
elle sent peut-être que selon ses choix
oui mais en même temps on sent que la
réaction un petit peu agressive c'est
une façon de se protéger aussi tout à
fait voilà je pense qu'elle est d'être
en manque de confiance en question
madame madame oui mais moi j'ai oublié
votre prénom madame soit à l'extraction
à part de moi là on parle d'infinité
jaillir sexuelle ça peut être ça peut
être une passade ça peut être un coup ce
qui peut peut-être plus engagé à ce qu
elles veulent épater
la finalité c'est parce que l'infidélité
sentimentale qui n'amène pas forcément
immédiatement à l'infini oui mais là on
est malade elle est beaucoup plus
engageante
est ce que est ce que vous avez constaté
ce phénomène absolument c'est quand
est-ce que ce que je dis quand il ya
chronicité dans le temps et dans les
sentiments et bien à ce moment-là ça
révèle une problématique de coupe non
résolus donc soit on se fixe sur l'acte
en lui-même d'infidélité à ce moment là
on souffre énormément
soit on essaie de passer au delà bien
sûr il faut que les deux continuent
d'avoir des sentiments est en vie
ensemble d'avancé mais s'ils y arrivent
s'ils font un chemin ensemble mais ils
en sortent grandis ça veut dire que la
fidéliser sentimental c'est plus
difficile mais il ya autre chose mais
rick perry qu on est passé par la
fidélité mais je sais même pas si elles
ont des atouts sur l'infidélité sexuelle
sentimental c'est encore anne hathaway
sa sortie du sua gâteau faire tuer oui
bah je sans doute d'une naïveté
ahurissante mais moi j'ai beaucoup de
mal à considérer l'infidélité comme un
remède potentiel ou une aide pour
certains certains coupe parce que pas un
remède pour moi elle est un conte le
révélateur d'un problème de fond aussi
des médecins du monde donc pour moi
l'infidélité c'est soir de la lâcheté
soit une fuite en avant ce soit
peut-être même de la paresse pour pas
affronter le problème du couple et de la
relation de couple
on a conservé la personne est un trompe
comme la faute il la personne fautive et
la personne trompée comme une victime
absolue sentir de les laisser tomber sa
logique les torts sont forcément sont
forcément partagé mais pour moi c'est
vraiment révélateur ou symptomatiques
d'une crise de couple qu'il faudrait
régler autrement qu'en allant voir
ailleurs par le dialogue la
communication ce que vous voulez et dans
l'inconscient collectif
dans le mien du moins l'infidélité
quelque chose de très tabou dissimulé
cacher et donc de l'entendre ainsi
assumer
à travers les nouvelles façons de
s'aimer le polyamour comme tu l'as remis
en fin ça sonne un peu mal à l'aise en
parlant de polyamour on à frédéric et
pierre qui sont dans le public
frédéric lapierre ce que vous pouvez
vous lever merci frédéric et pierre vous
êtes à la barre vous êtes 3 bat donc
voilà fredericks fier et miley alors
vous êtes potes tous les deux frédéric
et pierre laur qui alors frédéric c'est
qui frédéric merci merci d'être là
prenez le micro ans frédéric et vous est
pote avec donc pierre et vous êtes tous
les deux avec miley c'est ça c'est ça
ouais donc vous à pratiquer ce qu'on
appelle le polyamour vous étiez potes
avant tout les deux tous les trois vous
étiez potes on sait on s'est connu à peu
près en même temps et on a rencontré on
en rencontre et pierre maly - en fait on
est ensemble depuis 13 ans d'accord on a
rencontré pierre dans une soirée entre
amis c'est pas juste ce n'est pas juste
un trio il ya on a d'autres relations
aussi d'accord à huy sur d'autres
publics alors donc mais si l'on vous
vivez tous les trois ans
non non on vit pas tous les trois
ensemble
donc moi je suis ami avec pierre parce
que c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie aussi
c'est ça en fait c'est un peu comme les
amis de nos amis sont souvent nos amis
on a un peu les mêmes les mêmes valeurs
on a un peu les mêmes centres d'intérêt
etc
donc quand ce mardi après si une
personne souvent une personne que
j'apprécie aussi parce que sexuellement
mais vous ça vous dérange pas que miley
vous aimez vous êtes amoureux de miley
oui et et ça vous dérange pas qu'elle
soit également avec pierre ça me dérange
pas non c'est vous et en fait c'est
alors on a parlé de tromperie et tout ça
la tromperie ou l'infidélité c'est du
mensonge et c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'apprécie pas du tout on essaye d'avoir
des relations éthique comme toutes les
personnes sont au courant et pour moi ça
correspond beaucoup plus à mes valeurs
aussi et derrière ça c'est pas seulement
l'idée de coucher à gauche à droite il
ya ça correspond vraiment à l'être
d'autres choses c'est à dire que
les en fait dans le polyamour il
yal'idée aussi de sortir des normes en
général alors essaie on sort d'une norme
en particulier mais du coup ce que vous
formez un couple a trois ou est ce que
m'a irrité avec l'un et l'autre
séparément alors en fait moi je suis
avec frédéric et aussi avec pierre mais
on n'est pas dans une dynamique de
troupes
ok c'est donc c'est à dire vous voit
vous voyez une fois pied en une fois
vous vous faites des sorties tous les
trois ou oui oui après peut-être pour
vous éclairer en fait
[Musique]
moi ce que je trouve hyper intéressant
là dans votre émission c'est que vous
avez fait appel à nous dans ce cadre
très précis de l'infidélité et de la
fidélité
mais c'est vrai que je trouve ça hyper
pertinent enfin j'veux pas ce que vous
en pensez mais je trouve ça chouette
mais en tout cas parce que c'est vrai
que dans le cadre en tout cas du
polyamour dire qu'il songe très
spécifique voilà c'est ça il n'y a pas
en fait de notion d'infidélité
puisque vous êtes peut-être est-ce que
l'un de vous trois déjà été infidèles
aux deux autres ils ont là jamais autant
entendu sur un sujet sur l'habitude
l'habitude lui serait maya une heure du
matin là il est 23h30 et enfin la
question c'est ce que l'un de vous trois
déjà des lobbies autres oui non mais
parce que vous savez pas écouté la
banque ont expliqué les c'est là en fait
c'est pas si compliqué en fait comme je
vous disais ce qui est intéressant là il
ya différentes paradigme en fait parce
que dans le polyamour en fait le
consentement et consuel pardon
consensuel d'accord donc en fait si vous
voulez quand j'ai rencontré pierre je
t'ai déjà avec frédéric parce qu'on
avait coulé alors j'avais dit attendez
et moi c'est pas c'est donc lui le
savait qu'on était ensemble dont on ne
peut pas y avoir d'infidélité ou de
trahison mais vous avez dit à frédéric
vous avez dit frédéric je suis j'ai tu
tombe amoureuse de pierre aussi oui bien
sûr et frédéric vous a dit quoi c'est
génial
oui bah en fait on était déjà tous les
trois pattes en fait à la base
enfin moi j'ai des plaintes
j'suis pas avec leur femme mais bon
alors alors allez-y foncez frédéric hier
qu'ils prennent à dix et il est venu me
voir à une
un pique nique et m'a dit écoute obama
il ya là un crush sur toi mais comme
elle est vraiment pas doué au niveau de
la communication
je préfère passer sinon on va prendre
des siècles nom et est donc ouais et
donc et donc et donc quoi tu as dit quoi
alors moi je fais mon cadeau avec ce
genre de choses là donc j'étais
extrêmement mal à l'aise sur ce que je
vais la voir après on va sur une piste
après midi jean faire du karaoké des
choses comme ça qu'on sait regarder
vraiment l'un l'autre ont fait écrire
les noms sur une feuille des chansons
qu'on voulait chanter on était vraiment
en face à un côté l'autre parce qu'il y
avait un malaise clairement hamon a fini
par en discuter et puis bon voilà c'est
comme ça qu'on a commencé la rédaction
et la baisse est de retour là bas il y
juste une petite question vous vous êtes
vous êtes vraiment amoureuse des deux
différemment non c'est juste je
comprends pas trop la question mais
c'est à dire que vous aimez les deux
pour vous aimez les deux mais l'un et
l'autre pour des choses différentes mais
vous les aimez pareil c'est ça oui enfin
en fait vous savez c'est moi j'aime bien
en fait aussi les définitions d'amitié
amour en fait enfin jean fauque a pas
mal de chroniqueurs qui ont parlé il ya
beaucoup de cas par cas en fait oui tous
les individus sont singuliers et en fait
c'est intéressant de savoir quels sont
les définitions de l'amitié de l'amour
pour chacun est-ce que sur l'un qui met
debout dans un jardin qui vous demande
de choisir est ce que vous le feriez où
vous dites non c'est comme ça c'est les
deux en fait cela vous savez c'est comme
imaginer on a été parallèle un peu
étrange voyez enfin ça a pas vraiment de
sens en fait c'est un fait ça c'est
juste des contextes différents en fait
vous voyez enfin c'est juste une
question d'imagination imaginer un monde
parallèle si vous avez envie moi je vois
les bogdanoff wii ou en fait la
monogamie et l'exclusivité ne serait pas
la norme
d'accord c'est quelles sont les règles
que vous êtes fixés les les limites à ne
pas s'écarter des règles est ce que lui
il a le droit d'aller deux exclusions
droit d'aller voir d'autres filles où
vous seriez fâché non non je serai patch
break quoi je ne serai pas fâché
ah oui frédéric oui en fait pour mieux
comprendre je pense qu'il faut aussi
situer les choses
l'exclusivité amoureuse exclusivité
romantique c'est quelque chose qui a une
raison historique d'exister pour moi
c'est à dire que
il y à la domination masculine en avait
besoin nous les hommes de savoir qui
étaient nos enfants donc c'est sûr que
dans ces cas là il y avait le besoin de
contrôler la sexualité des femmes chose
qui maintenant on n'a plus besoin de ça
parce qu'avec la avec la pilule ou les
préservatifs
on peut savoir qui sont nos enfants quoi
c'est aussi une raison de fuites de
filiation c'est aussi une raison de
transmission du patrimoine
ce sont des choses en fait qu'ils n'ont
plus forcément de raison d'exister mais
on continue à perpétuer et les gens se
les gens sont pas au courant forcément
qu'ils ont de plusieurs choix possibles
guy mohamed juste en fait moi la base de
single day je pensais simplement c'est
un jour noël droit d'aller voir des
potes que le single day c'est une fois
par mois on a le droit de faire ce qu'il
peut avoir de très bons jours maintenant
prenez la même situation ces trois
personnages ne pas jouer un peu la
victime
mais si on prend mamadou mohamed dans un
reportage de bernard de la villardière
ça s'appellerait la polygamie est là
alors on est on arrivé à près de prendre
bernard de la villardière comme exemple
eh ben oui c'est pas pour rien et puis
on arrive là à cette vision un peu
consensuel on trouve ça sympathique on
trouve ça charmant
moi je suis désolé je suis peut-être un
peu vieux jeu je suis peut-être old
school dit que je suis langue de bois
peu importe mais je pense que
l'infidélité le polyamour ce n'est qu'un
aveu de faiblesse
et j'ai l'impression que désormais on
consomme les relations humaines comme on
achète un téléphone on ne veut ne plus
faire d'efforts pourquoi les gens
divorcent
car dès lors que ya un petit obstacle
dès lors qu'il ya un petit changement au
double x a fait partie du couple et on
n'accepte plus le fait que ça puisse ne
pas aller comme ça peut aller on se
marie pour le meilleur mais aussi pour
le mielleux pire dans las dans la santé
mais aussi dans la maladie et on trouve
un échappatoire et ce sentiment le
libérer dans l'infidélité jeu mais je
pense que ce n'est qu'un hack un aveu de
faiblesse
et je pense qu'au contraire c'est ce qui
détruira le couple après c'est comme la
vie il était très trop grade alors la
tendance mais ce que tu dis c'est bon
qu'eric pour le divorce peut-être le
raisonnement donné l'âge c'est une
relation c'est ça c'est accepter naturel
consensuelle les trois sources s'ils
veulent aller voir d'autres personnes
ils le disent franchement est ce sera
comme ça moi je vraiment j'ai rien à
redire du vendeur c'est accepter ces
sert à rien je me retire à c'est quand
même rare c'est à l'exception julie
bravo pour ce beau chat capable de le
faire
ah oui
nos policiers sur les capable merci
monsieur laporte s'étaient courtois avec
vous il omet dans le polyamour qui dise
le mot il ya deux mots qui m'ont choqué
quand même la pole respecte nos mais il
faut être en fait poliment moi je
croyais que c'était on sait mais hyper
police met en valeur le mot éthique et
valeurs je dirais ticket valeur pour moi
ça reste dans un couple et pas dans le
pôle ya maintenant une longère ils ont
des valeurs et je respecte mais ceux ci
un peu voilà un peu tard et labit
d'amidon dans notre éducation
soyons clair dans notre société on est
on est pas prêt à ça on est on est
plutôt éduquer former et même dans
l'exemplarité que nos parents nous ont
donné c'est plutôt une conception du
couple fidèle avec une famille des
enfants
là vous bousculer les codes quoi je vais
dire si c'est si en fait moi ça me
perturbe un peu votre système
alors justement on n'a le portrait robot
nous de l'homme infidèle
voilà on a le portrait robot de l'homme
infidèle alors je vous le dis je crois
que l'homme infidèle en fait je crois
qu'il est entre eux c'est un homme ils
enverront la quarantaine cheveux bruns
et courts les yeux marrons et cadres
supérieurs avocats banquiers architectes
vétérinaires chroniqueur il habite à
paris
mais suivant en union civile dont marié
voilà je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est
vraiment le profil tissus humains c'est
d'avoir mis la photo parce que là ça ça
devient presque une émission de
télé-réalité moi je fais pas ça alors il
a trompé par penser aussi les personnes
qui sont en couple par exemple il ya un
mec qui va se masturber devant un film
porno excuse moi quand il va voir la
nana il aura envie d'elle donc s'est
trompé par conséquent je voudrais ne
critiquez pas mes hobbies alors on a on
à solène payet qui est avec nous vous
êtes directrice de la communication du
site de rencontres extraconjugales
gleeden alors qu'ils donnent donc ça
existe depuis dix ans c'est quoi alors
c'est un site aussi un site en fait de
niche qui va cibler les gens qui sont
mariées ou en couple et qui ont envie de
faire des aventures extraconjugales mais
on met rom et mais ça ça c'est donc la
personne d'avoir tout de suite son
fameux non non l'idée en fait la
création du cirque déjà c'était de
prendre les 30 % de gens qui sont sur
les sites de rencontre classiques est de
les prendre pour faire une plateforme à
eux dédiés en sécurité parce que c'était
une étude qui a été faite à l'époque en
deux minutes on s'est rendu compte
qu'ils avaient 30 % de gens sur les
sites type mythique etc qui en fait
avait un profil mais se disaient
célibataire mais manquait pour avoir une
aventure extraconjugale corps donc
surtout bien ça marche très très bien on
est en croissance continue du breuil le
lancement on va atteindre les 5 millions
de membres dans cette année donc plus de
la moitié en france et donc vous en être
fier mais ça montre vraiment qui a un
besoin avant même le lancement du site
en fait on avait cent mille préinscrits
quand on fait l'apologie de ces
pathologies
ces composés répond également métro
c'est une apologie de l'ain
d'élite et je suis désolé une affaire
des chances est sous le choc est ce que
ça vous autres ce site qui donne bien
sûr
moi j'aimais d'hypocrisie les gens
savent où ils mettent les chiches et au
moins quand on a des personnes qui
parfois d'un site de rencontres
attendent une vraie histoire d'amour
final on tombe sur un homme ou une femme
meurt avec des enfants au moins on sait
où on va oui j'aimerais juste tire ces
gens là avaient besoin de guide
mais au moins il n'y a pas dit pourquoi
sylvia marchait vraiment qu'il réponde à
la demande
arrêtez ces fonds en moi je fais partie
donne je trouve ça donne que tu disais
crevaison alors d'habitude tu me tues
ben t'es plutôt anti capitaliste est
plutôt en afrique moi l'idée l'idée
compliquée avec arthur et du commerce
sur un truc comme ça ça me semble
incroyable ça va vous parler d' apologie
mashov le mot est un peu fort mais enfin
les a cités
non mais je dis le moi est ce que vous
faites à tromper c'est pas une apologie
pas tous en même temps un jour qu est ce
que vous êtes fier de faire un travail
qui commercialise
l'idée de l'infidélité enfin j'ai monté
cette cause d'infection à l'e j'en ferai
les joies de conscience aiguisée raynaud
les volets sit in j'aimerais qu'on
laisse pour l'instant je suis réaliste
je vous avais aussi vous êtes choqués
par ce dossier mais bien sûr vous avez
aucune valeur je sais même pas comment
vous faites pour dormir la nuit ce genre
de les découvrir
valeur et la gestion de votre travail je
comprends mal mais excusez one question
penser les gens n'ont pu aller voir
ailleurs non non service à des gens déjà
sollicitations c'est bien dans soit
c'est un parfum son couple est calé sur
ce site le site répond à gâteau s'il
vous plaît cette famille idéale et brisé
bien chaud l'aide c'est bon que des gens
sincères sur ce créneau pour faire de
l'argent moi ça me paraît logique que ça
ça me choque pas mais en revanche
effectivement quand moi j'ai vu pour la
première fois la campagne d'affichage de
gleeden dans le métro comme vous le
disais moi ça m'a complètement interdite
est ce que le père look et c'est le fait
que ça existe celle ci avait marqué je
m'en rappelle très bien premier site de
rencontres extra conjugales on se doit
de penser par les femmes
exactement on a justement mis le point
sur l'infirmerie féminine séduit pro
crise issue pour cacher sa verrière pas
du tout un pillage sexuée michelin
publie des féminines et le dernier vous
êtes dans le cynisme n'est pas du tout
et vous êtes dans l'extension de la
marchandise a séduit les derniers bouts
devient un produit tout devient une
marchandise mais le nom mais on excusera
une infidélité masculine ne vous cachez
pas derrière j'ai fini le mur alors ce
sera mieux répétition en 1975
est ce que fait soleil à brad hand a
tonné m qni est où il est choqué par ce
site vous moi je suis pour une liberté
qui ne connaît pas forcément de limite
dans la pratique sexuelle dès lors
qu'elle est conforme à la loi dès lors
qu'elles ne heurte pas véritablement les
mains les bonnes moeurs dès lors qu elle
ne met pas en cause et des comportements
concernant les enfants alors est ce qu
ont le droit de faire ce qu'il vous
plaît madame vous réponds vous parle
vous parlez trop même temps que tout le
monde je vous aime beaucoup mais il faut
se calmer que prévoit la loi en cas
d'adultère a donc il ya deux choses
différentes c'est vrai que l'affichage
peut provoquer effectivement des
désastres concernant les enfants
mais la pratique est le même c'est la
question qui m'étaient posées dont pose
aucune difficulté
pardon excusez moi j'ai oublié votre la
loi prévoit quoi contre l'adultère ccc à
des rabais la loi oui c'est un délit à
condition que vous soyez marc marié
vertus dont il ya pas d'adultère en
dehors du mariage
bien évidemment un et contrairement
d'ailleurs à une idée assez tenace
l'adultère le le dieu de divorce pour
faute subsistent et par conséquent le
fait de tromper son conjoint constitue
une faute une faute
alors qui a connu des évolutions c'était
avant une faute dit péremptoire serre
que le juge était tenue de prononcer le
divorce au tour de celui qu'il avait
commise aujourd'hui le juge l'a précis
mais dans la réalité des faits
l'adultère est constitué comme je dirais
la faute principale est ce que la
personne qui trompait et toujours la
victime est ce que la personne trompée
et est toujours la victime alors c'est
intéressant comme sujet parce que je
pense qu'effectivement ce au niveau de
la justice
on ne recherche peut-être pas
suffisamment ce qui était à l'origine de
la treille et on va pas chercher en un
mot la tendance à considérer que le
délit est un délit je dirais factuel et
objectifs et à partir du moment où il
est constitué on s'intéresse pas trop à
la question de savoir pourquoi ils aient
été commis après il ya des difficultés
- vous tu fous beaucoup de gens qui
commettent
dû lutter on va dire ou qui vont
chercher ailleurs parce qu'ils ne
trouvent peut être pas chez je sais que
le devoir conjugal
les marques chinoises lucine frappe ça
parce que c'est pas lui c'est une faute
mais à condition de pouvoir le prouver
c'est très difficile de prouver un fait
négatif que vous vous le savez en droit
alors naomi haut depuis tout à l'heure
vous les voulez parlez vous vous êtes
vous ne pouvez pas vous empêcher de
tromper vos partenaires si vous êtes
donc pour le single d mais voilà le
signe que le nez c'est à dire pouvoir
tromper son partenaire une fois par mois
et même vous ces voix là c'est vous
oui est-ce que vous lui mon pied est ce
que vous vous le faisiez dans le son
dôme à ce que vous lui disiez alors
avant je le faisais dans le dos
maintenant j'assume donc vous dites à
vos petits copains je vais te tromper
c'est sûr ouais mais après ça que ça
colle après moi je veux justement
trouver une personne qui accepterait
justement fin qui me plaisent aussi
cette relation après moi j'adore séduire
j'adore tenter de nouvelles expériences
mais je ne vais pas arriver quelque
chose je passe de la psychologie de
comptoir si l'histoire mais déjà
énormément
donc moi je suis preneur
c'est la production encore qui fait nos
caméras sérieux s'arrêtera finalement
sérieux on a des classes matures c'est
un peu toujours été mon ami à lui
mais je suis dépassée je suis un vieux
[Applaudissements]
calais joly ait très joli e
non franchement on va voir se répéter
les spectateurs si dans un an je
m'attendais pas à ça alors oui alors
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous chez
vous l'infidélité est elle la clé d'une
réussite d'un coup oui à 11 % non à 89%
c'est un plébiscite c'est un petit peu
comme ici voilà les b
vous voyez pas ce que c'est vrai que ça
rejoint un petit peu ce que vous dites
que vous n'arrivez pas à trouver
quelqu'un voilà qui accepte vos
infidélité